the race is a 12-episode long anime
directed by tomohiko eetu who is one of
the primary directors behind sword art
online and better yet Death Note and
this anime follows the story of a guy
named sitar oh who has something he
refers to as revival he'll be walking
around in everyday life and suddenly get
a flash-forward of something that's
going to happen
however he doesn't quite see what's bad
but he knows that something's off and
when he gets this flash-forward he has
to instantly look around and find in
pinpoint what might be off so then when
he reverts back into normal time which
is usually just a few minutes behind he
can then find whatever's about to happen
and stop it and in the first pilot
episode we find out that he uses things
like that to stop car accidents and
other smaller things from happening
where someone could possibly get hurt or
killed but suddenly he wakes up as a kid
in grade school again he has gone so far
back with what he called revival that he
is now a child he's no longer an adult
and he has to figure out why he's been
sent back to being a kid again to
hopefully prevent a terrible string of
murders so he has to sift through all
the clues of an 18 year old unsolved
mystery while also being in the body of
a child but having the brain of a 29
year old still maintaining his school
his grades his friends his relationships
and it's pretty awesome in fact this is
my favorite anime that I've seen I can't
even remember actually I thought about
this quite a bit before turning on the
camera for this review I can't think of
an anime that I've liked more with in
the past 10 years really erased is that
good it's a very taut gripping
psychological thriller but it also has a
really great sense of humor the large
arc of this anime revolves around a
young girl who was murdered
now adult Satoru knows that she was
murdered and when he goes back to being
a child he feels that this is the murder
that he's going to have to stop so that
his life can eventually grow up to be
better but more importantly so this girl
can be saved so watching this character
struggle to connect with this
introverted girl to hopefully save her
life in the long run was really touching
and actually extremely emotionally
affecting it really surprised me and I
can't believe I'm actually sitting
reviewing this because I watched tons of
new anime and I tend to focus more on
anime that I've seen in theaters when I
do videos like this but whenever I see
an anime that impacts me as much as this
one did I can't help to share my
thoughts with it and I strongly strongly
recommend this show after I give my
grade I have something else I want to
talk about in regards to this anime and
the way it's being distributed and it
doesn't have much to do with the quality
of this show so I'll save that for the
end of this video
so tarou's mom in this show is probably
my favorite anime mom ever she is the
best mom like you could ever have she
understands virtually everything about
this guy in fact he has a joke
internally throughout the entire show
that he's positive his mom's a witch
because she just predicts everything
that he's about to do and she
understands everything that he needs at
that exact moment he needs it the most
all the way from childhood to adulthood
and I found that also really hilarious
and that's something I really love about
the show is that although it is kind of
dark since it is about a serial killer
that's abducting young girls and a young
boy who has to figure out how to stop
all this from happening the show has a
great way in maintaining a light tone
while also being a coming-of-age story
although our main character has already
technically come of age because he's an
adult in a kid's body so it's a very
interesting way of looking at this and
that added to the drama of it all and it
made it considerably more impactful than
I think it would have if it was just
about an adult trying to solve a mystery
it's a detective story from the
standpoint of a child with an adult's
brain and there's also a time-travel
aspect to it so it just makes it so
unique there's certainly nothing like
this in America that's for sure as soon
as somebody would say that it's an adult
brain in a child's body getting to know
a young girl instantly all American
studios would be like no we can't have
that that's inappropriate but this show
has a great way of telling this story
without it ever being creepy even the
more creepy aspects of this story are
handled with maturity which is another
thing about this show there's a very
serious dark subplot involving abuse
parental abuse and obviously the serial
killer and it is disturbing but it's
handled with a surprising amount of
respect for the children that are
involved
whenever I see anything whether it be a
movie an American TV show or a Japanese
TV show handle something as dark as the
subject matter in this show while also
maintaining a sense of humor and have it
all be perfectly fluid that's majorly
impressive and from episode 1 all the
way to episode 12 I was constantly
riveted by a race - my biggest issue
with the show is that I basically
figured out that the killer was about
halfway through and it didn't really
surprise me there weren't as many
options I think as there should have
been in regards to who it could be so
when you find out who the killer is I
was like yeah I figured that out but I
mean it didn't stop me from enjoying the
show because the characters were so well
fleshed out and so well-rounded that
everything else around that I was really
excited by and I actually don't even
want them to make a season - some people
are so in love with the show they want
more if they do make more I'll watch it
but I think this story ended amazingly
if they made a film that might be cool
but I really don't think they need to go
anywhere else with this story I'm going
to give erased and a slice now as I said
I want to talk about the way this anime
is being distributed and how it is truly
bothering me but first I do want to make
sure you guys know that my promotion
with Adam tickets is still going on
that's 8000m tickets it's a fantastic
app that allows you to buy movie tickets
directly from your phone before the film
starts you can pre-order concessions
even skip the line all of your friends
can buy tickets for one movie you're
going to but you can set it up so that
you can all taste separately I think
it's a fantastic app and the best part
is is that if you use the code crisp you
get five dollars off your order for the
rest of the entire year so please do
check out the link I've left in the
description below and check out this app
and download it for your Android or your
iPhone and let them know that I sent you
if you can thank you very much guys now
let's talk about this specific thing
that's been bugging me quite a bit
ever since I purchased those two
blu-rays right there this is a 12
episode show and that's it it's complete
it's done now these two volumes cost me
187 dollars
that's insane I did the math to go to
Amazon right now you can buy all nine
seasons of Dragon Ball Z on the official
blu-rays for about one hundred and
ninety dollars if you have prime
shipping and you don't have to pay for
shipping now that's a ninth season show
with over 200 episodes twelve episodes
on to blu-ray sets a hundred and
eighty-seven dollars are you insane
this is distributed by Aniplex and I
bought it off the right stuff anime
website contrary to what you might think
I don't get that much sent to me for
free
I go to screenings of films yes so I
have to follow embargoes but in regards
to anime I pretty much buy it all myself
this is an insane price why did I pay it
because I want to support anime and I
want anime to be distributed in America
and I wanted to come to my area in Ohio
and when I see something available I
want people to know that it's wanted and
desired people who are distributing
anime I want anime to come to America
and I wanted to come over to a fair
price so I always try to support it
99.999% of the time I will buy whatever
is available perfectly legally 100%
legal
I don't like streaming I don't like
downloading things that I'm not supposed
to download because I like supporting
the artists very rarely will I ever pick
up an anime bootleg I have like a couple
and that's only because they're simply
not available anywhere literally I have
like a couple anime bootlegs that have
never been distributed in America and
that I wanted to see one of them was the
show monster I think there's like Volume
one of that show I have an anime bootleg
of that and I mean for the most part
like I said 99.9% of time I am buying
the actual official release but come on
Aniplex this is an absurd price you're
asking people to pay it's a 12-episode
show you know it's just crazy i bought
it because i want to support it but I'm
almost ashamed to say how much it costs
for me to watch a 12-episode show that's
just nuts
I don't really know what I'm trying to
accomplish by saying this other than to
lett anime fans out there like me know
that I feel your pain when it comes to
things like this that's just a crazy
price it's almost unethical it's a
really absurd price for a 12-episode
show if anyone from Aniplex is watching
this just take that to heart please
because because that's really it's just
kind of wrong so expensive it's just not
necessary
but I must reiterate do checkout erased
it is one of the best anime that I have
seen it's really that good and I
strongly recommend it guys thank you so
much as always for watching and if you
liked this you can click right here and
get stuck my knives
[Applause]
[Music]